come out.
So my talk today inshallah isahill
is the key to paradise.
And as I mentioned in the today in masid
that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam and he said in the authentic
hadith
our words revolve around asking Allah
for paradise and seeking salvation from
the hell. In essence that's the goal of
every believer whether male or female
Jenna and being saved from the
punishment of may Allahh protect us all
from it. M
>> and the key to paradise
beingahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahah
is is not something that is invented by
me because when we make statements like
this there has to be some type of proof
and evidence and that's important for
every Muslim to learn their religion for
themsel because allahel
in many verses in the Quran he commands
us with to follow the revelation that
has been revealed from him subhan
not to follow me. I don't call anyone to
follow me blindly or to accept
absolutely anything that I say unless it
is supported with proofs and evidences
from the Quran and from the sunnah of
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
with the understanding of the of this um
the first and foremostly being the
companions of the messenger of Allah
sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
This statement
being the key to paradise. You can find
it in Bkari. I brought Bkari with me
even though I prepared my lecture here
on my iPad. So to serve as an
encouragement for all of you to go away
and learn from the classical sources of
Islam, from the Quran, from the Sunnah
of the Prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam, from the classical works of
when you learn for yourself, anything I
say that is correct, alhamdulillah, you
will be able inshallah to recognize that
it is correct. Anything that I say that
is an error and it's possible because
I'm a human being. I'm not
only the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam was infallible as it relates to
conveying the religion. That's why
he said everyone's speech can be
accepted or rejected except for the one
who was in that grave meaning the
prophetat.
So look this can be found in alkari.
But how many of us read alkari?
How many of us have ever read a chapter
in Al Bkari? If I was to ask a question
right now, what's the first book in
Bkari?
How many could answer? And I'm not
trying to catch anyone out. I'm just
trying to show us the importance of us
learning our religion. Alhamdulillah.
Many of you are in university. So
obviously
you have excelled in academic studies,
but that doesn't guarantee understanding
of the religion. That's just a meme in
Alba. You have some people who have no
academic studies but they have more
understanding of the religion of Allah.
If you can gather both, alhamdulillah,
excellent. But the most important thing
is understanding of the dean of Allah to
implement it correctly. And you should
understand that just from
guide me to the straight path, which is
one of the most comprehensive
supplications. But you ask for guidance
to the straight path. But that entails
you learning what the straight path is.
Na. So can anyone tell me the first book
in Bkari?
Huh? Somebody said I heard a whisper.
Anyone else?
>> Revelation.
>> But do you know the exact title?
>> There's a word before it. But but again,
what does this highlight? It highlights
before we even go into the lecture. We
can't learn our religion from a random
YouTube video or Tik Tok or a debate in
high park. We have to take time to learn
our religion.
Knowledge is acquired through learning.
Again, anyone in university knows that
if you have an exam, you have to
prepare. If you don't prepare, there's a
possibility that you may fail.
Not even acquired through learning. So,
I'm going to mention the chapter. This
is in
the book of funerals in Bkari the most
authentic collection of on the face of
the earth.
He has the chapter chapter
whoever's last speech is
and there's a hadith of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam in
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
he said
whoever's last words
they will enter paradise may Allah bless
you all to die
whoever's last words Allahillah
they are going to enter paradise.
Bkari didn't mention the hadith here.
Does anyone know why the actual hadith?
He just mentioned the chapter hadith.
And again, this is something that
alhamdulillah you can learn for yourself
and understand for yourself. Why?
Because when Bkari compiled this book,
he had conditions. The hadith is
authentic, but it did it didn't meet the
conditions of Albarim. That's why he
just referred to it in the chapter
heading. Then under that chapter he said
it was said to
one of the imams of the students of the
companions. It was said to him
is notahill the key to paradise. So
that's where the title of the talk it
comes from. Okay? Not from me because if
I said is the key to paradise I need to
have some type of reference
[clears throat] for that. You have the
reference alkari. You can go back and
find it inshallah
in the first chapter.
So they asked what is that the key to
paradise based upon the Quran and based
upon the hadith of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
he responded
certainly yes it is the key to paradise.
He said, "However, every key has ridges,
the teeth of the key. If you come with a
key that has the necessary ridges, the
proper ridges, the door will open for
you. If you come with a key and it
doesn't have the correct ridges, the
door will never open no matter how hard
you try." And that's given a parable, an
example, so that we could all understand
it. A key, we all know what a key is.
The ridges on the key. If the ridges are
broken, you try and open the door, the
door will never open.
What are the ridges referring to here?
Anyone?
>> We said the key isah which is but what
are the ridges? Thean
>> conditions.
>> The conditions
has conditions. Does anyone know the
conditions? We don't have any gifts, but
does anyone know the conditions
ofahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahah?
Anyone?
[snorts]
>> Yeah, I want the Arabic and the English.
Knowledge.
>> Knowledge. Explain a bit more easily.
What does that mean? Knowledge.
>> You have to have knowledge about the
meaning.
>> You have to have knowledge of the
meaning
ofahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahill.
[snorts]
Allah commands itah.
No have knowledge ofahillah. Understand
it correctly. You have to understand it
the correct meaning. Again, some people
sayahillahillah
and they have the wrong belief
concerning it. And I'll give an example,
an example of that. Those who
sayahillahill but they believe Ali is
Allah.
That's not going to benefit them. Why?
Because they don't have the correct
meaning.
That's clear to everyone, right? If you
sayahillah but you believe Ali is Allah
or Jesus is Allah, are you a Muslim? No.
The first condition. Secondly, somebody
else
>> which is what?
>> Certainty.
>> Certainty. The third
>> you accept it. Everything it
necessitates from youallah it
necessitates that you worship allahel
alone you accept that. Anything
connected to it you accept it. Somebody
calls you to it you submit.
We hear whether they're younger than you
whether they're older than you.
You know what's the fourth?
>> Which means what?
>> Submissiveness.
>> Submissiveness that you surrender to it.
The fifth somebody else.
Yes.
Yes. The fifth condition.
What's the fifth?
Truthfulness. Meaning you have to be
truthful when you say it. You can't be
lying. Now we know the they lie when
they say it. Hypocrisy is that you
pretend to be a Muslim with your tongue
but in your hand in your heart you
disbelieve.
You're sincere when you say it. You say
it seeking the face of Allah. You don't
say it just because you want to get
married. No, you say it withas.
And the last being what? Alahaba. You
love it and you love everything that it
indicates and everything that it demands
of you. You love everything related to
it.
Now they're the conditions
and again it's upon every brother and
sister to learn about these things and
study about these things. If we don't
know them, we don't know the basics.
These are the fundamental basics of our
religion. That's the most important
statement
is the reason why Allahel created all of
us. That's our reason for existence. As
Allah said,
I did not create the gin of mankind
except to worship [snorts]
me alone. That's the very reason why we
exist.
is the reason why Allah sent all of the
prophets and the messengers, every
single one of them.
Is the reason that Allahel created the
heavens and the earth and everything in
them and everything between themahill
is the reason why paradise and hellfire
exists.
The people of it, they will be in Jenna
and the people who reject it, they will
be in the hellfire.
as I mentioned in the today
is the reason why the earth will
continue to exist
whenahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahillah
is absent from the earth that no one is
sayingah
no one is implementing it Allah would
destroy the earth because there's no
good in it can anyone mention a proof of
that
anyone mention a proof of that again
that requires proof because it's from
it's from the knowledge of the unseen
that whenah when when there's No one on
the earth that is saying
the earth will be destroyed and
everything in it and the hour will be
established
in the immedah
the meaning is one the hour will not be
established meaning the earth will not
be destroyed until it is not said on the
earthill
then Allah will destroy the earth
because there's no good in it
and the hour will be established upon
the most evil of the people. Why?
because they don't have
that is my brothers and sisters that is
the foundation of our success as we will
establish inshallah
and there are so many and I'm going to
talk about them some of the virtues
ofahillah
the excellence ofah to the extent that
scholars have written books about this
the virtues and the many points of
excellence relating toahillah based upon
the Quran based upon the sunnah of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam as we
mentioned one paradise Yes. If you die
saying believing it in your heart,
implementing it in your life, you are
guaranteed Jenna
is a promise because it's the key to
Jenna.
But you have to implement it. You have
to abide by it.
Sayingah, but I'm going to the grave and
I'm calling upon the dead. It's not
going to benefit me because again,
what's the meaning ofah?
Anyone tell me the meaning? What
doesahalah mean? Everyone should know
this. Every Muslim I can bring mashallah
some of our Shabb the youth maybe two
years of age. Mashallah that we raised
them and said they used to raise their
children as soon as they were able to
speak they would teach them to say from
the first words that they would utter
would
again highlighting the significance and
the importance of this because if you
grow upon it you say it you believe it
you implement it and you die in it
you're going to ja and you're guaranteed
paradise. What's the meaning ofah?
>> There's no god worthy of worship in
truth except Allah.
>> Do you know in Arabic that I'll give you
that? There is no deity worthy of
worship in truth except Allah. Do you
know in Arabic?
And again I'm going to take you back to
the scholar. Somebody may say well
that's you came with that meaning.
You know that word that they like to
throw around.
If you caught a
and if you try and implement the sunnah
regardless of where you are in the world
there may be someone they say wahhabi
people like nicknames this was before
Muhammad and Abdahim some will say
this was before
some will mention other people and
that's why I want to go to the classical
sources in Islam again
let's fact check right when they have
debates in this day and they have
someone facteing.
When I speak, fact check
where do you fact check? You can go back
to the classical sources of Islam. I'm
going to mention
one of the im the scholars some of say
his
mother of books of the Quran. Anyone who
came after him relied upon him in some
way or shape or form.
He said the meaning
ofahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahill
when allahel he saidillahill
nollah
understandahill
he said
Allah is commanding the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam no
the meaning Know oh Muhammad that there
is no one who deserves or is fit for
divinity and for whom worship is
permissible for you or for all the
creation except for Allah. the same
meaning. Is he a Wahhabi? He lived
nearly what 900 years
give or take. Maybe somebody can again
check it before Muhammad.
Was he a quote unquote wahhabi? Let's go
to
again an im of he has a these are books
that are in the library of every serious
student.
And when a verse is quoted from the
Quran,
people quote verses.
The people of truth will quote verses.
The people of falsehood will quote
verses.
You can check it.
He said,
meaning Allah is the only one who
deserves to be woripped.
Allah is the one deserving of worship
and frustration. None besides him. So
those who came after him, yes, they
would say
means none has the right to be wor in
truth except Allah.
It does not only mean
there's no creator except Allah. That's
part of it. But at the time of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
the ptheist of they believed Allah was
the creator. They believed that Allah
gave life and Allahhana was the one who
controlled death. They believed it. If
you were to ask them who created the
heavens and the earth, they would say to
you surely Allah. But they worship other
than Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. They
committed shik.
Likewise, brothers and sisters, this
is the first obligation and it is the
last obligation.
It's the first obligation. What does
that mean? You find some of the scholars
saying
The first obligation and the last
obligation
isahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahill
for someone to enter Islam they have to
say theahillah
so it's the first obligation
it is the first obligation
likewise we know
Islam is built upon five the first
pillar the shahada and the testimony
none has the right to be worshiped in
truth except Allah and that Muhammad is
the messenger of Allah all of the
scholars agree if this is not present a
person is not a Muslim.
The prayer there's a difference of
opinion between
the one who abandons the prayer out of
laziness are they a Muslim or not? The
scholars differ on it. Some scholars say
that the one who abandons the prayer out
of laziness based upon the verses of the
Quran and the hadith of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam which is the
immedah they say the one who abandons
the prayer out of laziness they're not a
Muslim. Other scholars say yes the one
who abandons the proud of laziness they
are Muslim but they are sinful Muslim
they're fifi
but as for the first pillar of Islam the
scholars unanimously agree whoever does
not possess that they are not a Muslim
that's the first obligation
the first obligation in dawa how many
people do we see talking about these
things our universities and ISAs they
should be full of people talking and
teaching about this most important
subject because it's the most important
thing. This is the thing that any growth
and development is built upon. You can
pretend that you have development but
without it there will be none. When the
prophetat
and the hadith is authentic, he went to
the people he said when he was calling
the people of Mecca
sayahillah
so that you may be successful.
They said that behind the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam there was a
man who was crosseyed with a radiant
face and he was saying he is a liar.
He's abandoned the religion of his
forefathers.
Who was that person that was following
the prophet saying that accusing the
prophet of being a liar? Does anyone
know? If you studied the you should know
>> Abuah his uncle
there's a benefit in that success
prosperity.
Now the more you actualize that in your
life, the more you perfect it, the
happier you will be in the and we'll
give other proofs for that as well.
Happiness even goes back to and the the
actualization and the perfection of this
if you perfect it when you are living in
the as we know
there are 70,000 people from my nation
they will enter paradise without any
reckoning and any account. They are
those who perfected. they perfect this.
So even in the those individuals they
are the best of the people
but another benefit from that and his
wife when you implement that in your
life when you teach it when you call to
it there may be some opposition the
prophet's uncle the prophet went from
being a
he was known as the trustworthy one the
one who only spoke the truth if the Qur
they differed amongst themselves and
they needed a person to arbitrate for
They would go to the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam because they trusted his
integrity and his honesty. He was
upright morally
religiously.
However, when he went to them and he
said, "Oh, people sayahillah,"
his own uncle was saying he's a liar.
So do you think that when you're calling
toah when you're teachingahim when
you're implementing
everyone's [clears throat] going to
throwing out roses for you?
No, it's [snorts] not the case because
there's going to be somebody in
opposition. somebody who's practicing
shin people who are worshiping idols,
people worshiping graves, people
worshiping all types of things, prophets
and messengers and righteous people and
other
again the first even in doesn't mean
that yes we teach but we teach other
things as well but how many places do
you see teaching these topics in detail
not just generally in in Bkari you have
a chapter it's one of the chapters in
this book again was Why aren't you
a chapter?
The prophetat he sent when he sent him
to give to he said
you're going to the people of the book.
Let the first thing that you called them
to be the shahada the testimony. None
has the right to be woripped in truth
except Allah and that I am the messenger
of Allah. The first thing if they accept
that tell them Allah has made obligatory
upon them. Five daily prayers in the day
and in the night if they accept that
tell them about zak but the foundation
is what
because the mush of they used to make
around the even though they used to make
it naked may Allah protect us from that
and that's showing that immorality is
coupled to shik they're connected when
shik is present in a land you will find
immorality connected to that that's a
reality
they used to make
they used to make some form forms of
remembrance. Many of those forms were
but none of it was accepted from them.
Why? Because they didn't have the the
foundation which was
likewise
from the the virtues ofahill is that
no one who dies upon it will remain in
the hellfire forever. No one who dies
upon it will remain in the hellfire
forever. We find that in the Quran.
Whoever associate partners with Allah,
paradise is forbidden for them. That's
that's what's stated paradise. If
someone commits sh they die upon shik,
they will never go to Jenna. Doesn't
matter what good they do. They can be
the best humanitarian. They can go all
over the world. That's something that is
good. But Allah will recompense them in
this world. They will receive the reward
of that in this world in the they will
have no good. Why? because they didn't
have
the opposite understanding of that
paradise is specific for those who die
until
we have the hadith beautiful hadith
again showing the wordingahill because
I'm trying to highlight specifically
when this is mentioned the prophetat
it's in Bkari and also Muslim
They will they will they will exit the
fire meaning the hellfire. The one who
saysahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahillah
none has the right to be worshiped in
truth except Allah and in their heart is
good equal to the weight of [snorts] a
body green they will come out of the
hath because some Muslims may be
punished in hell. May Allah protect us
from that. When is that? If somebody
dies committing major sins without
repenting [clears throat] as he said,
the one sin Allah will not forgive you.
If a person dies upon a ship, which is
the opposite to someone [snorts] dies on
it, Allah will never forgive it.
Allah will never forgive you. Some
someone dies on major ship major,
they're in the hellfire forever. May
Allah protect us from it.
But he forgives anything lesser than
that. Meaning major sins lesser than
that [snorts] lesser than they fall
under the will of Allah. So someone
steals that's a major sin but it's
lesser than someone drinks alcohol. It's
a major sin and the threat the
punishment is severe. Someone gets high
that's a major sin and the threat is
severe but they are lesser than shik. So
if someone dies in that state that
person he falls under the will of
allahel and again this is derived from
the ayah and there are other from the
sun of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam. This is the sunnah [snorts]
is what? Someone who commits a major sin
lesser than in this world they are known
as amin
they believe but their faith is
deficient or they're known as a a simple
Muslim in this in the hereafter
those individuals who die from the
believers
but they die upon major sins that are
lesser than without repenting. So they
didn't repent from them sins because if
they repented from them they don't have
any sins with a sincere repentance they
fall under the will of Allah in
if Allah wills he will forgive them and
they enter paradise immediately
but if Allah chooses he will punish them
but eventually after they they are being
punished they will be brought out of the
hellfire and they will enter paradise
but who wants to risk that that's why I
mentioned the hadith in the today
beautiful hadith that the importance of
forgiveness And the connection to this
topic
Allah said in the
Oh son of Adam,
oh son of Adam,
as long [snorts] as you call upon me
alone, as long as you place your hope in
me, I will forgive you regardless
[snorts] of what sins you commit. And I
shall not I shall not mind you.
Adam.
Oh son of Adam.
Oh son of Adam. Look because we're going
to fall short. All of us. None of us are
perfect. None of us are angels. The
angels Allah has really said about them.
They don't disobey Allah. They do what
they have been commanding. As for me and
you, we are going to make mistakes.
All of the children of Adam will make
mistakes. The best of those who make
mistakes. The best of those who sin are
those who repent to Allah. So we're
going to make mistakes. None of us are
going to be impatible. But when you make
a mistake and you sin, you repent to
Allah. But your repentance will not be
accepted unless you have
the last part of the look how it's
connected all together.
You have an Adam. Oh son of Adam.
If you come to me, if you come to me
with the earth full of sins,
if you come to me with the earth full of
sins, sins less than a ship, meaning
you're still upon in your speech, in
your heart, in your actions,
as long as you do not associate partners
with me, meaning as long as you don't
make shik. So look, every Muslim should
be hearing these texts from the Quran
and the Sunnah. When Allah says, "Allah
will never forgive." Meaning if you die
in it, I will forgive you as long as you
do not commit. Everyone should be
saying, "What is shik so I can stay away
from it?" What does it entail so that I
can avoid it?
If you stay away from that, Allah said
in the I would come to you with the
earth full of forgiveness. So the
forgiveness of Allah is conditional on
you staying away from shik and being
aillah. May Allah bless us all to die
upon that.
And that is a good ending. When you see
someone dying and they say
and they die upon that, that's a good
ending. But for a good ending, there's a
book by
that I advise every brother and sister
to read especially in our societies and
any society. And I'll mention a
description of the book and maybe you
can tell me the title of it. Somebody
went to imbar
Islam and look at the excellence of the
scholars and they had a question. They
were falling into a major sin. It
doesn't mention what the major sin was.
There are indications of what it was but
there was no specific mention of what it
was. And they said I fear that's going
to destroy my worldly affairs and my if
I keep on doing this sin. That's a good
sign. But how many of us like that if
we're doing something that is in
disobedience to Allah that we worry
about it and that it bothers us. Yes. If
it bothers a person that's a sign of So
he went to and he said I need advice
because if I continue doing this filthy
act is going to destroy my and my
[clears throat] wrote a whole book.
What's the name of the book without
anyone screaming out? You already
answered a lot. Somebody else.
Somebody else
you've already answered right
>> the disease and the cure and it's
translated in English.
Take some time even outside of your exam
revision or whatever you are doing to
sit down and read that book and it's
very easy alhamdulillah to read. Some of
the scholars have mentioned that that
book should be present in every language
because of the benefits that it
contains.
with the what? The disease and the cure
and there's no greater disease than
that's a disease that will ruin the um
[snorts] may Allah protect us from that.
Now the is
and whoever said none has the right to
be worshiped except Allah
and has in their heart good faith equal
to a weight of a wheat grain they will
be [snorts] they will leave the
hellfire. They will they will not remain
in hell forever. So lookahillahillah
whoever dies upon it even if they have
major sins they will not remain in the
hellfire forever. They will be in
paradise. It's the key to ja either
immediately or eventually
from the excellence ofahillah.
It's a means for success, happiness, and
it removes distress. And I'll give a
proof of this from the Quran with the
sun of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam. In life, you go through ups
and you go through doubts. There are
times that you're going to laugh.
There's times you're going to cry. No
one can escape that. Life is not always,
as they say, a bed of roses. How do you
cope with the difficult times? Everyone
can cope with the easy times.
The more you actualize you will find
alhamdulillah the happier you will be in
the
a proof of that that
it will give a person by the by success
from allahel it will be a means for a
way out is the story of ununice
he was swallowed by the wave
he was in three layers of darkness
the darkness of the night,
the darkness of the belly of the whale,
and the darkness of the sea. Imagine
being out at sea. If a whale swallowed
you,
would you have any hope of being saved?
And I don't think any of us in life, no
matter what you've gone through, none of
our struggles are equal to the struggles
and the trials of the prophets and the
messen
The people are trout the most are the
prophets
that's factual. If we know the stories
of the prophets from the first prophetat
to the last prophet the messenger
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam
the first messenger was whoat
wasam first prophet was Adam was
so whatever we go through in life is not
going to equal the struggles and the
trials of the prophets and the
messengers youatam
he was swallowed by the way
some people may give up that's The more
you actualize
the furthest thing from a person's mind
that actualizes the with their tongue
with their heart and with their action
suicide. It would never come into their
mind showing the importance of belief.
We find in the Quran
he called out into the darkness of the
light making dua
showing the importance of belief. Belief
is the foundation for lions.
Again, the change of the um is not going
to be through just influences. Anyone
can just do that moment while the camera
is there. That's easy. Anyone can
pretend, you know, I used to do this and
I used to be that. I used to be a
gangster. I used to be that. That
doesn't mean anything. What is it here?
And that level of success it comes from
Allah alone.
Firmness comes from Allah.
Example
of that
when they dragged him through the
streets of Makkah and the narration is
in the of Ahmed hadith
he would say they made him bake in the
sun with armor. He would be forced to
wear armor and bake in the sun and he
would say
Allah is one. One in his lordship, one
in his sole right to be worshiped alone.
one in his beautiful names of perfect
attributes. Allah is one that was at the
beginning when he accepted Islam.
That strength came from Allahel alone
again through the
soil.
You want to see called out into the
darkness and
none has the right to be worshiped in
truth except you look
glorified and exalted are you meaning
Allah is free of all imperfections but
we affirm his beautiful names and we
affirm his perfect attributes
I was from the wrongdah
saved him from the belly of the whales
and it's not only specific to unice
>> because Allah tells us this is how he
will save the believers difficult times
if you turn to if you turn to Allah with
your Allah he promises you a way out.
Whoever fears Allah at those times Allah
will give them a way out. Even though
that verse is in it applies for
everything.
Whoever fears Allah, Allah will give you
a way out. Difficult times you turn to
Allahel.
You actualize that this this servitude
to Allahel alone in your speech, in your
behavior, in the belief in your heart.
Allah will give you a way out. Like he
gave Ununas a way out. The prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam said in the
authentic
the supplication of ununice
when he was in the belly of the whale.
None has the right to be worshiped in
truth except you glorified and exalted
are you. Indeed I was from the
wrongdoers.
No Muslim calls upon Allah with this
except Allah will answer their dua.
No Muslim supplicates with this except
Allah will answer their dua.
Showing the importance of what?
Likewise,
the virtues from the virtues of
this hadith we find in other collections
of
Allah subhana t will address a man
specifically from this nation from my
nation in front of all of the creation
on the day of resurrection.
99 scrolls will be spread out for him
and each scroll will be as long as the
eye can see.
Meaning 99 scrolls of evil deeds, all
his bad deeds. May Allah protect us from
that.
It will be said to him,
do you deny
after you deny any of this any of these
bad deeds? The man will say no.
He will be asked
did the angels who record the actions
did they oppress you? He will say no my
lord.
It will be said to him do you have any
excuse
heard? He knows that the proof has been
established against him. The the truth
reached him and was established against
him and also the angels had recorded
everything and Allah has revealed is all
knowing. Nothing is hidden from Allahh.
So when we stand before Allah there's no
excuses there's no
so he will say I don't have any excuses
then
it will be said to him you have a good
deed you will not be oppressed today and
a card will be brought forward and on
that cardahill
none has the right to be worshiped in
truth except Allah and that Muhammad is
the messenger of Allah
will be placed on one pen of the scales.
A scale. You have a pen. You have a pen.
This this card will be placed upon one
pan of the scale.
All of the 99 scrolls with all of those
evil deeds on the other scale. It's
mentioned at the end of the hadith
that the 99 scrolls will be light and
the card containing will be the
heaviest.
Why?
Because there is nothing heavier than
the name of Allah. There's nothing
heavier thanah.
Again showing us the importance of
learning aboutahill and that this is the
key to Jenna. Take a portion of our life
to learn about it. making sure that we
implement it correctly because there are
people that are beautifying all types of
things. You don't want to die and you're
worshiping a prophet or a messenger or
you're worshiping a tree or you're going
to a grave and you're taking the soil of
a grave and you're people are telling
you you know you drink it with honey and
such and such happens from the baraka
where is this
you don't want to die and you're wearing
an amulet and you believe that amulet
can harm you or benefit you other than
allahel that's major or you're wearing
an amulet
still and even if you don't believe that
and you believe It's a means a
protection. It's still minorship.
You don't want to die in that state.
You don't want to die in a something
that opposes to in the absolute sense
from major ship or it opposes its
perfection from minorship.
How do you avoid it? Knowledge.
Knowledge. Not listening to everyone on
the internet. I'm sure you've all seen
I've seen it myself. I don't know.
There's a person. He goes around and he
just spits on the mic and everyone's
screaming. I don't know what what's his
name. Chauff.
Do you want to be followers of chauffe?
Because look how many people attend
his gatherings
thinking that this is Islam.
I just saw a video in Egypt, the grave
of Badawi, a guy, Subhan Allah, in some
type of alim
and they're supplicating to this dead
person in the grave and some of them are
dancing and other than that and even
disobedience to Allah. How do you avoid
that brothers and sisters? Learning for
yourself, learning Quran, learning
Sunnah.
According to the understanding of the
companion, somebody says something about
the religion, you ask them for proof.
Anyone who gets upset when you ask them
for proof there's something wrong. Imm
Ahmed he used to say don't take my
statement blindly. Don't take the
statement of blindly. Don't take the
statement of this one blindly. Take from
where we took from
learn your religion. That's why I said
yesterday to the classes, regular
classes once a week
from
the three fundamental principles for the
books of knowledge. It can't always just
be we're just having a gathering. We're
having a coffee gathering. Mah
everybody's there coffee gathering. We
have a lesson. There's three people
there or maybe no one. No. When the
prophetat wasam Medina was conquered by
the Quran, not the sword. That's why
said whoever says Islam was spread only
by the sword, they align. Why is that?
There was no sword that opened Medina.
It was the Quran.
The prophetat wasam the first thing he
he did was send the companions who had
knowledge of the Quran to go to Medina
and teach the people the Quran.
That's what conquered Medina because it
would open the hearts. Even now in
America, subhan Allah, I can speak about
the city. I'm in Philadelphia. Ramadan,
we had I think it was over 400 people in
our masid alone embracing Islam. Why is
that? Because they understand that
none has the right to be worshiped in
truth except Allahel.
One, it resonates with the inate
disposition. As they say, if you leave a
baby and there was no influence of
society, no corruption of society, they
will grow up to believe in God. We know
that from the hadith. We know that from
the Quran.
Okay. Yes. They arrived at it now in 20
whatever. We knew that from the Quran,
from the Sunnah of the Prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam. Allah took
that covenant.
None has the right to be wor except him.
That's innate in every one of us. It's
innate. If the fra is if your fra is
pure, that's innate. You know that's the
truth. You It's like a magnet because
the fra is Islam.
that Allah created every human being
upon but it's the parents that corrupt
the child society and other than that
likewise logic
logic that's the only conclusion there's
one God we worship him alone
prophet can't be God because a prophet
is a human being he was selected by God
to deliver the message of God but we
worship his creator
we don't worship prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam we don't
worship Jesus says we don't worship any
human being. How can you worship a human
being that was breastfed or that uses
the bathroom like you they are human as
it relates to those type of things.
That's why it's for those people that
say that the prophet was created from
light and he was light. How was he
created from light when she said that
when she woke up in the middle of the
night the prophet was praying and she
was searching and she felt his foot. If
he was light he would have been glowing.
Look how we don't need
the proof will conquer falsehood in its
original form. That's why many people
are embracing Islam. Also the statistics
I think it's from the Pew Institute
about people leaving Islam
and I think it's statistically flawed.
But again people embracing Islam in
those numbers. Why? Because
alhamdulillah
also according to revelation
the first of the ten commandments
shows the importance brothers and
sisters of learning about this again
implementing it in our lives and calling
to it and teaching it and making sure
our children are firm upon it. Yes,
learning how to pray correctly is built
upon that. Learning how to fast is built
upon that. learning how to give zak if
you have your wealth reaches the and a
year passes
is built upon that everything else is
built upon that without that everything
collapses
so take some time to learn about this
and I'll close with two hadith inshall
another virtueah
is the best form of remembrance
the best remembrance isah the best thing
that you can remember Allah with Can
anyone give me a clue for that? And I'm
sure you all know it.
I'll give you a clue. It's connected to
the day of
I can't really brother. Do you know it?
It's connected to the day of
>> it was asked what was the best thing to
say.
>> Anyone else? What is the dua the taught
to say on the day of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam? said
the best dua is the dua of the day of
the prophetat he said the best dua the
best is the supplication on the day of
the best thing I have said and the
prophets who came before me none has the
right to be worshiped in truth except
Allah alone without partners. To him
belongs all that exists and to him
belongs the praise. And he has he is all
powerful over all things. That's the
best.
That is the best.
Likewise, I close with this. The
happiest of the people. The prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam on the day of
resurrection, he will intercede for the
people of a condition. You have to die.
Otherwise, he cannot intercede with you.
Why? Because intercession
one is only with the permission of
Allah. Allah gives permission to the one
who is interceding and for the one with
intercession is sought.
[clears throat] That's why when they
went to the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam in the long
the greatest intercession on the day of
judgment the day of resurrection
they went to the prophetat and they will
ask the prophet to intercede with Allah
for judgment to begin upon all of the
creation. And the prophet will go to
Allah and ask permission and it will be
said to ish to it will be said to
intercede your intercession will be
accepted. So Allah has to give
permission also. The one for whom
intercession is sought has to be from
the people of you can't intercede for
the mushik.
The uncle of the prophetat
Abu Talib is going to
because he died upon which is the total
opposite to
even though he has least of the
punishment of the people of the hellfire
but still may Allah protect us from any
punishment in hell.
The prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
the happiest of the people to attain the
prophet's intercession are the people of
you want the prophet to intercede for
you in the hereafter you have to be from
the people who live upon and they die
upon as I said not only saying it with
the tongue saying it with the tongue
believing in it correctly and acting
upon it with your limits there comes in
the
he said,
"Who are the people who's going to be
the happiest of the people with your
intercession on the day of
resurrection?"
The prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
said,
he said, "Abu, I didn't think that
anyone would ask this question before
you." That's a proof. Some people say,
"Abu, he only narrated hadith. He didn't
have understanding. That's nonsense. The
prophet praised his understanding. I
didn't think anyone was going to ask
this question before you why
because I saw your zeal in learning and
another benefit of that story
he accompanied the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam for a given number of
years but he narrated the most had so
it's not about time it's about the
blessing that Allah places in your time
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
responded he said
The people who are will be the happiest
with my intercession on the day of
resurrection are those who say sincerely
from their hearts from their own souls.
May Allah bless us all to receive the
intercession of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam. But how do you receive
it? You have to die from that.
If you worship the prophet, you will not
receive it because you worship other
than Allah. There's no difference
between someone who worships Muhammad
and somebody that worships Jesus. May
Allah send his salah and salam upon both
of them. Is that clear to everyone? This
is something that no Muslim can have
shak about. Again, I'll stop here to
give some time for any questions.
As I said, scholars have written books
about this subject subject.
Anything I said that is correct, it is
from Allahhana. Anything that I said
that is an error, it's from myself and
thean and Allah and his messenger are
innocent and free of them. No.
So inshallah if anyone has any questions
ask the chef now and we're putting the
computer back on and for the mint meter
anyone who uh wants to ask questions
online they can do so as well.
[clears throat]
>> Who should we take knowledge from and
what do you think of someone who says
that we should take knowledge from
everyone because we can't say who is
definitively wrong.
>> Now it's a good question. Um who should
we take knowledge from?
And what's the response of someone who
says that we should take knowledge from
everyone? I mean, I'm going to preempt
it with a so that person they take
knowledge from chapa.
Look how ridiculous that statement is.
We don't take knowledge from allahel.
Again, that statement, somebody makes a
statement when we analyze whether we
accept it or whether we reject it. If
somebody does an action, whether we
accept it or whether we reject it, we
weigh it in accordance to the Quran and
the Sunnah and
let's analyze that statement again
because I may say something what I'm
saying could be true, what I'm saying
could be false. I think we all agree on
that premise.
That statement we take knowledge from
anyone.
Then allahel in the Quran he said
ask specifically he mentioned
the people of remembrance people of
knowledge. He never said ask anyone. So
if we take knowledge from anyone why
wasn't it said ask anyone.
So yes, if you know, alhamdulillah based
upon Quran and Sunnah, you know, but if
you don't know, Allah directs you to a
specific group of people.
Likewise,
[clears throat] we find a
explained in the Quran. Allahel mentions
in the Quran
that
as for those who have a disease in their
heart, they want to follow the unclear
verses of the Quran
because they desire chaos and they're
looking for a false explanation to
support their corrupt belief or actions.
That verse in the Quran
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
explained it. He said in
corrected this hadith father
and again she is from the narrators of
hadith who narrated
she's from amongst those who narrated
the most hadith from the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
that is why some this difference of
opinion who is the best of the women
from the female companions some of them
say some of them say the middle position
is what
as it relates to aiding Islam at the
beginning
as it relates to spreading knowledge,
Allah raised them. Why? Because of their
knowledge of the Quran and the Sunnah.
And that's what we need. We need more
women to be serious in learning the
Quran, learning the religion, and
teaching it. We don't need more models
on hygiene. We don't that there's enough
of them.
We don't need more influencers. We need
women that can teach that have the
confidence to express themselves now
based on knowledge. Na'am likewise they
can write or you're oppressed clarifying
I'm not oppressed in the slightest and
eloquently they can explain that for
themselves because they can speak better
for themselves if we speak for them
they'll say oh look you oppress the
women they can't speak no so she
narrated the hadith explaining the verse
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
said
if you see people and they always coming
with unclear verses unclear evidences
they are those whom Allah is referring
to stay away from it.
Somebody say yes that's talking about
non-Muslims though again
the Sahabah how did the companions
understand that verse because somebody
say when you say that's only talking
about non-Muslims it's not talking about
Muslims no the companions understood
also that verse and they applied it to
the Kawari who are Muslims
and they said we don't take knowledge
from the Kawari
we don't learn from the Kawari rather we
know the position established all of the
companions agreed about the position
towards the Kawari who are Muslims.
So this thing about we take knowledge
from everyone is not correct. I ask the
person who says that right you take
knowledge from anyone as it relates to
religion. Do you also go to any doctor
you just meet a man on the street you
say listen yeah I think my I might have
kidney failure here operate on me. No
you don't your religion is more precious
than your body.
Your religion is more precious than your
body. That is why again if you open up
Sah Muslim in the introduction to Sah
Muslim there's the famous narration of
Muhammad he said when fna differing
occurred when the sex appeared and this
is a historical fact you can't deny it
we would love for the Muslims to be one
um may Allah unite us from Quran and
every Muslim should hope for that
[cough] but the reality is Muslims they
split into sex it's a historical fact it
was foretold
They will continue to differ except
those who Allah has mercy upon. The
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam told
us
whoever lives down you will see much
differing.
So as
when the appeared no one said yes go and
learn from anyone you can learn from the
you can learn from the no you learn from
people that you trust their knowledge.
You see from them a brother asked me
today he's a layman. He said he's new.
He said, "How can I?" We're living in a
time of confusion. No doubt everyone's
claiming to be upon the truth. He said,
"How as a you know, as a beginner, can I
determine
who should I listen to or what should I
listen to?" The first thing I say, learn
your religion.
We find in the dua,
my lord, increase me in knowledge. So I
advise everyone to learn for themselves.
The way you will be able to
differentiate if you learn learn the
Arabic language so that you can
understand the Quran. Alhamdulillah you
can read the Quran. Learn the
the basic tools to allow you to
understand
various discussions as it relates to
Islam [clears throat] but also certain
things alhamdulillah are obvious. If you
have somebody talking about sunnah this
and the sunnah of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam mashallah we have to
follow the sunnah. Yes, we have to. No
doubt.
The prophetat wasam he said whoever
turns away from my sunnah they're not
from me. But if somebody comes and
they're saying this but they
shaven no sunnah
no sunnah in their appearance you don't
see sunnah. They're eating and drinking
with their left hand. Me as a layman I
know there's something going wrong here.
He's saying sunnah sunnah but he's
eating and drinking with the left hand.
I don't see any sunnah with this person.
So certain things are obvious.
So establish the basics of what we know.
Also if I see for example individuals
they never quote ayah they never never
quote they never quote for example
understanding of sahaba I know
something's wrong. If I hear I think but
if it starts off you know how it starts
off in our time I'm an expert in this
field. So you have to listen to me.
Anyone who starts off with that I'm an
expert be weary. It doesn't matter
whether you're an expert. What matters
even experts have to follow Quran and
Sunnah. And how many experts have got it
wrong and how many lay people because
they follow what they know from the
truth have got it right. Success comes
from Allah not intelligence. That's why
there's a famous statement of famous
statement of
he said the people many people of
intelligence they've been given
intelligence but they have no purity in
their beliefs and in their actions
Aristotle and all those philosophers
they may have had intelligence but they
were the most corrupt and immoral of the
people Freud who were for example
psychologies based upon his ideas some
of his views were very outlandish and
immoral and indecent
so So they may have had a type of
intelligence but they was physic they
were spiritually corrupt and rotten.
So again that's my advice with regards
to that you know learning for yourself
learn your religion take time to learn
me I was mentioning to the brothers m
I'm familiar with this building you know
I I I used to study the foundation here
I graduated from uh pharmacy
the redwood building but I used to come
here and I because of the library here I
think it's the chemistry library no when
I first went to university in King's
College in 96 when I went to London one
of The reasons I left studying because
it was everybody was there at that time
everybody
everybody was there everybody saying I'm
right everybody's wrongd
always had an inclination to Quran you
know and being familiar with the
scholars however I said I'm studying
related issues here I'm going to learn
the language for myself because at that
time people quoting verses you know the
famous verse that the they quote to make
on everyone that disagrees with them and
it's a verse of the Quran but it has
this correct understanding
whoever does not judge by the ruling of
Allah they're the
at that time I said you know what subhan
Allah in order to be able to go back to
the classical works of Islam have to
know the Arab alhamdulillah the best
decision I left you at that time
alhamdulillah because dunya is there
it's going to be here when you get back
it's not going anywhere
so I advise you I'm not I'm not saying
you know I'm just saying take time to
learn your religion that's the point
don't go take time to learn your
religion even if you are here
should have lessons
they should have lessons where people
are learning learning the same way the
companions learn the same way the learn
the same way the learn the same way that
we see scholars teaching now if you god
was teaching the six books of hadith in
the mid of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam the way of learning doesn't
change. Now technology helps sh if I
want to research a hadith I could type
one word preparing the talk
alhamdulillah access if I want to find
something one before the that we used to
use as it relates to finding words in
the Quran you had to do it by the the
the reference you now I could just put
in one word in for example which is a
program that alhamdulillah has many of
the books of knowledge yes you use
technology but the same way you still
have to learn the same Quran so
understand
so I encourage the brothers and sisters
to learn how to look. Any other
questions? You've already asked the next
I don't see any questions. So I don't
I was just wondering because you said
that it's very important for us to
integrate like
Muslim like he sort of puts it into our
lifestyle.
>> Yeah. Do you think there is any sort of
like background knowledge from someone
that I don't think like I don't think
myself to be very knowledgeable. So um
is is there any like sort of background
knowledge almost in or something or a
pathway almost to like try and integrate
those type of books into our lives?
>> Obviously you start with the basics you
know you start with the basics. There's
as it relates to seeking knowledge some
chapters alhamdulillah will be very easy
to to understand for everyone
you know the book of knowledge the
chapter
knowledge precedes speech and actions. I
don't think that's over the head of
anyone, you know, but some of the
chapters in the start of revelation very
easy to understand. If somebody was to
say like, you know, I want to study
right now and I'm a beginner. What
should I start with? I wouldn't say, you
know, study bkari from the beginning to
the end and you don't have a teacher to
do that. I would say alhamdulillah,
study what you can learn and memorize
that which you are able from the Quran.
Likewise, sit with a teacher that's
going to teach you the correct meaning
of what you learn from the Quran or
benefit from the books of the scholars
like
a simple and other than them start for
example maybe with at the same time for
the
three fundamental principles the
questions of the who is your lord who is
your prophet what is your religion
whether you do it
or whether you readab from Alb Bukari.
Now there's stages to things. The most
important thing that you rely upon
people alhamdulillah scholars that are
credible and can be trusted.
Alhamdulillah you can recognize them. If
you study with true scholars you know
who the scholars are. You know the
scholars you know of our time some of
them passed away.
A man who served the sunnah of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam his
whole life. You know
you know many people they give and you
will hear says it's sound
also
there are still senior scholars and
other than them and also Mhammed Adam
Ethiopia an Ethiopian scholar who has
probably the most expansive explanation
of one of the best explanations of
Muslim now you know those type the the
caliber of scholars. We don't have them
in the English speaking world. Somebody
will say, "Yes, people, we have scholars
in the west." If you're talking about
scholars as it relates to academia, as
it relates [snorts] to in academic
standards, then okay, the loose usage of
the term,
there may be some legal. But if you're
talking about scholars, the likes of as
I said Ali, the likes of Muhammad Adam
and Ethiop, the likes of Mhammedi,
I say, and it's a challenge. Maybe
somebody can prove me wrong. Bring me
one person in the Western world that we
have a section in our library for their
books in Arabic that all of the um
refers to. Oh, many of the um refer to
I don't know any.
If you go to the library now you have
will have a section. You go to the
library you have will have selection and
other that he may have written will have
a section and the other scholars from
the scholars of Islam. Now that's not
everybody but that's from the
distinguishing science because you know
as it relates to you they benefit from
each other
people who recognize people of virtue
are those who have virtue. It's like
somebody who's the best doctor in the
world as it relates to heart surgery.
I'm not qualified to speak on that. I'm
not a heart surgeon. You can give me the
you know somebody maybe in the back
streets somewhere in the world and say
he's the best surgeon. I'm not going to
be able to differentiate the same way
for a layman to say he's the most
knowledgeable scholar. How what are you
using to judge? But the scholars
themselves they know who are the people
of N. Now
check the questions on the computer.
Okay.
Can you explain what you mean by people
who worship prophets, saints? What
constitutes worship?
Worship
as mentioned by the people of knowledge
is a comprehensive term to describe
everything Allah loves and is pleased
with from the statements and the actions
and the reality of worship, the essence
of worship.
is the utmost level of love and the
utmost level of submission. Now worship
is the sole right of allahel.
The mass they belong solely to Allah. Do
not call upon anyone other than Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. Do not worship
anyone other than Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. Worship like what? Dua. Duas
worship based on the Quran based upon
the sun of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam. The prophet said it clearly
[snorts]
supplication is worship
likewise
sacrifice another vows and other than
that
these forms of worship if they are
directed to other than Allah is made so
if someone directs calls upon Jesus made
someone calls upon prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam made someone
calls upon
ordi
major ship. If a person fears them with
with the fear of worship, you fear them
to such a level that you worship them.
Now, you fear that they're going to harm
you and they're in their grave. They
call it supernatural fear, major
Worship is the sole right of Allah.
What's the difference? That's why I
asked and again I had a discussion with
Sufi in when I was in Houston and we
never chased him down as the some of
them said on the internet. He came to
our gathering. We didn't at the
beginning cuz it was a gathering of
brothers and in the gathering
alhamdulillah a lot of people came and
he came and we were sitting for a long
time and at the end I discovered because
he kept asking questions they say they
say but it was a long discussion. I
asked him, I said, "Would you say that
it's okay for someone to worship
the idols that used to worship as long
as they say Allahel is our lord?" He can
answer because that's what they say. You
can worship the dead people, you can
worship the prophet as long as you say
Allah is my lord. So I asked him, do you
say you can worship as long as you say
Allah is my lord? Couldn't answer. Why?
because that shows the falsehood of what
they actually believe. No, whoever
directs worship to Allah is a mush.
No, we don't saint worship.
There are religions that saint worship.
It's not Islam. The Muslim worships
Allah. Islam is what
we submit and surrender to Allah with
worshiping Allah alone.
We free ourselves of sh all of its forms
and manifestations. That's why Islam in
the general sense every prophet was a
Muslim. Meaning they worshiped Allah.
Every prophet came
with the same message.
All my people worship Allah. None
deserve to be worshiped except him.
[cough]
Every prophet came with that. No.
I've heard statements such as if your
husband is not happy with you, you will
not enter paradise. What if you haveall
I mean it's a threat. It doesn't mean
yes as we said that person who dies upon
it is going to jer definitely
that person who dies uponahillah is
going to paradise definitely as we said
if you perfect it immediately if you
have sins that are lesser than shik
from the major sins now that person
falls under the word of Allah is good if
Allah punishes them eventually they will
be brought out from the hellfire and
they will end up in paradise but Allah
may forgive them and they go to Jenna
immediately it's like for example tail
carry
It's a major sin. It's a major sin.
Backbiting it's a major sin. So there
there are major sins but they fall under
the will of Allahh as we explain.
Are there any videos on YouTube where we
could learn about the books regarding?
Yes, many videos. Firstly, there are
many books translated into English with
the explanation of the scholars. One of
my personal favorites is uh
the explanation of
from the contemporary explanations.
Likewise in mas a summary of the
explanation of aed by
likewise if you go to our masid
uh in English masid YouTube channel we
have lessons in we're close to finishing
it inshall you'll find many lessons
and I encourage you to study this and to
learn it inshall and give time to it.
[snorts]
There's a there's a question here that
says there's a ballot box in a masjid to
vote. What's your advice? The masjid is
a place of worship. It's not a place of
politics. It's apolitical. I mean, our
position when people come to us in in
the when we're in Philadelphia, we say,
"Listen, in our masid, we're here to
teach people religion. We're not here to
tell people who to vote for.
We're here to teach people the
religion." The masjid is a place when
the man the bed urinated in the masid.
The prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
he said the masjid is not a place that
this should be done in
the mid was built for the remembrance of
Allah and the prayer.
The masid has a role. Now politics
outside of the masjid and as you know
politics is a dirty business. I remember
subhan Allah they was telling people was
telling people in America to vote for
Bush. How did that go?
>> [snorts]
>> So again I would advise Islam you leave
the masid free of these type of things.
The masid we're not everyone knows
what's taking place all over the world.
Everybody knows about majority of the
people know knows about and understands
what's taking place in terms of the you
know the race baiting and the division
that we see but the mid is the place to
learn people and give them the tools
alhamdulillah to understand the religion
so they can implement it correctly and
that also will help them navigate in
life and make the right decision in so
I'd advise you to stay far away from
those type of things.
If one person wants to start learning
the where should we start
>> 40 hadith 40 hadith why didn't know
write 40 hadith he said many people
preceded me collecting 40 hadith about
specific topics he said I wanted to
gather 40 hadith that address the
fundamentals of the religion of Islam so
if somebody just wants to generally
learn a hadith of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam then I would advise them
the 40 had of because he he compiled in
that book a number of hadith that he
believed would clarify a number of the
funament fundamentals of the religion of
Islam and it's true you see clarified in
a number of those
rejection of
being clear and other than that he
finished the hadith with the I gave
the I mentioned son of Adam as long as
you call upon me and place your hope in
me I will forgive you regardless of what
you have of sins and I I shall not mind
he closed
for the hadith with that
the exact reason may be showing that
even if you fall short with regards to
your implementation if you seek Allah
has forgiveness Allah will forgive you
may Allah forgive all of us now
>> what's [clears throat] the most
authentic
place to like search hadith online
>> one place I mean authentic place to
search a hadith you can there are search
engines where you can search for example
what the scholars will analyze the
various books of hadith say. So for
example again you can go and see what
say the immed with the checking of for
example
you can go on and you can click the
checking of
and you can see how they judge the
it's in knowing what books that you
refer to. I think that's the best
question. What books can you refer to to
check uh the gradings of certain hadith?
Obviously outside of Bkari and Muslim
many scholars alhamdulillah past and
present have already fulfilled that
service. It's just learning what those
books are and referencing them. Even
before there were books that
alhamdulillah if you wanted to research
a hadith you could go back and basically
look what the scholars say with regards
to the authenticity or the weakness of
those hadith. Again it's about learning
inshall. Now for the layman what should
the layman do? Because you might not
have anything of the knowledge of the
science of hadith. You do not know how
the scholars arrive at the conclusion
whether a hadith is weak or whether a
hadith is authentic. Whether it deserves
to be in bkari or whether it deserves to
be in the du.
Then as the scholars they mention
you can blind and follow a scholar that
you trust as it relates to that you
trust them in their knowledge and you
trust them in their dana their
religiosity
unless if it becomes apparent to you
that that scholar is wrong. Allah shows
you because of your knowledge, what you
acquired of knowledge or what you learn,
it's obligatory upon you that you leave
the statement of that scholar and you
follow the truth. Then you will be
blamed with when you know that scholar
was wrong. For example, he made a
mistake. He relied upon somebody else's
authentication or whatever it happens.
You know, so and so said such and such
and they didn't have the time to
research for themselves. But then it
becomes apparent to you because of the
knowledge you gained over the years that
that scholar was wrong. Now you will be
questioned. Are you going to rigidly
adhere to that scholar because of your
love or you going to follow the truth?
And may Allah bless us all to follow the
truth.
Best self-study for Arabic language, it
differs. Bias is going to appear based
upon how a person learn and what they're
familiar with. For me, my bias is the
Medina books because I studied the
Medina books. I like the Medina books. I
like the Medina books for a number of
reasons.
The Medina books were written by a
scholar, alhamdulillah of the language,
may Allah have mercy upon him
specifically for the University of
Medina for people who did not have a
firm grasp of the Arabic language to
learn the Arabic language and prepare
them for the kulyat the colleges where
they would go on to learn the religion
in Arabic. So the Medina books one, two
and three also with the sister books
that go along with them like how to
speak and express yourself. They have
various books which help you gain
knowledge of because learning Arabic
comprises of three things
Arabic grammar and they teach you that.
Likewise
uh vocabulary
and they teach you that as well and also
sub morphology how to break down the
words. Right? So I I advise people
[cough] with Medina books and
alhamdulillah there's many videos online
where people are teaching Arabic for
free. Again when I started practicing in
Cardiff there was no no one Allah
according to my knowledge that was
teaching anything on a consistent basis.
There may have been like a lesson
you know one week and then there would
be no less no lessons for the the next
few weeks. Now alhamdulillah in this day
and age you can go on the internet you
can learn from the comfort of your own
home or there mashallah you have mad you
have I know specifically ban is being
taught likewise Quran alhamdulillah we
have individuals who memorized the Quran
with them and other than that if you're
unable to attend you can go online
nadim I think he's completed nearly all
of the three medina books again the
lessons are free but as they say if you
put effort you will attain inshall and
should every Muslim should try try and
learn Arabic when you hear the Quran you
can understand it imagine you prayaw
alhamdulillah you know in Ramadan and
you you're understanding what the imam
is reciting when you open the you read
the Quran you can understand it for
yourself there's no greater feeling then
you don't have to rely on a translator
what did they say
no problem
>> can I asked where you stand on let's say
the dollar of groups like arts and do
you think that overall they're doing
positive for
the brother asked he said where do where
do you stand in regards [clears throat]
to groups like
again as it relates to anyone you know
our allegiances to the Quran and to the
all you who believe answer Allah and his
messenger when he sallallahu alaihi
wasallam called you to that which will
give you life. So my allegiance has to
be for Allah and for the messenger
sallallahu alaihi wasallam when
allegiance is for groups or parties
and we see clear errors. So for example
I'm with a group and I see them in the
mid they have graves and those graves
are being worshiped and they don't say
anything about it. There's a problem if
I'm defending that group and or I'm
turning a blind eye.
Now so firstly the brother asked with
regards to the mount of
this is what I believe to be the truth
based upon proofs and evidences proofs
that I've read myself interactions I've
had with them personally and what the
scholars have said about them thoroughly
in their books
a book that was written a long time ago
probably near the start of that book uh
that group there are many fabricated
hadith in there and that innovation and
false beliefs. They've been advised
about it by numerous scholars, people
who were with them and advised them and
they up until today that book is still
being taught by them. And again just
having a we know them to be a liar on
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
and saying the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said such and such. The prophet
said in a hadith which is
whoever lies upon me intentionally take
their seat in the so when we say the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam and
he said we have to know that this is
established in the sunnah that's one
issue with innovations there are
innovative practices that are promoted
in that no proof from the Quran or the
sunnah no proof from the companions of
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
also you have false beliefs that go
against the beliefs of
again why is it that they're still
teaching that book up until today and
they will not correct it or they will
not refer to books that are like
alhamdulillah which
are way more reliable and don't have
those problems that I mentioned I've had
discussions with brothers again I've
seen with my own eyes I've prayed in
Newport there's a I was in Newport I was
working at the time I was working at and
I went to Juma I didn't know what the
masid was I just look for a masid. I end
up in the masid and the person's there
and the mimb and he's making dua to the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam. He's
saying
and I see on the wall it was a mid. So
there's in the masid at the time there
was one of them. I said to him brother
you speak he speaks. I don't speak
please advise him that this statement is
a statement of shik making dua to the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam. The
brother said to me and again I'm forgot
forgotten until today. This statement
remain with me. He said brother I'd say
anything is going to cause fitness. What
fitness is greater than sh? What fitness
is greater than sh? And up until today
the scholars advised them you know
decade after decade advising them to the
extent that if you look originally
and others said go with them to teach
them originally right when they realized
that they won't accept those who advised
them and point out the errors and
they're going to remain upon the vid the
innovations that they're upon
and the false interpretations then the
scholars they said stay away from them
because those who are superior in
knowledge to you have tried and they
don't want to change whatever they're
upon. Now, as you're asking, you know,
about do they do good? No, calling
somebody to pray in the masid is an act
of good, but we're talking about should
you rely upon them or not. We're going
to mention whether they're reliable or
not in their general sense. But
obviously, alhamdulillah, calling
somebody to pray is something that it is
good without a shadow of a doubt. But
does that in itself override the other?
No. And it's when you go with them, you
go with them, they've come to me, come
brother, come 40 days.
40 days stand up and give taleim
how can I give I have no knowledge we
were sitting in mid a masid here in we
had a lesson
brother came he said brothers go out to
give da I said this is not da we're
reading alhamdulillah we have a you know
Quran
you know outside is da da based upon
what da'wah we say in the Quran
say this is my path I call to Allah. So
again it's not it's not about emotions.
It's not about allegiances. It's about
truth. Those who conform with the truth
I'm with you. Whether I know you whether
I don't know you whether you're in
Pakistan, whether you're in India,
whether you're in China,
that's the relationship that we have.
But if you oppose the truth as it
relates to the fundamentals of the
religion, then you're on your own.
At the end of the day, I can't justify
the errors that you're upon. And if
somebody asks me, it's a religious
responsibility. Allahel has taken a
covenant from us that we speak with the
truth. Even if it's about your mother
and father, even if somebody asked you,
say for example, we had at the time of
the nar hadith, people would say about
their children, my son, he's a liar.
Why? Because you can't take hadith from
him. It it's wicked to say that. Should
we accept this hadith? This is now
whether you should take knowledge or
not. He can't say that's my son I love
him you know yes you should learn from
him he said my son he is a kea don't
take hadith from him or whether it was
relating to their father relating to
their uncle because it's a matter of yes
in your approach you are wise and you
deal with people with wisdom we have to
speak the truth
so yes I don't advise people to
accompany those groups with those type
of errors I advise you to learn
alhamdulillah advise them to come back
to what is correct and yes we should go
out comes from the what Can anyone tell
me what does come from in the Arabic
language?
>> Huh?
The prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
said convey for me even if it's an ayah.
So we should do but our should be in
accordance to the Quran and the Sunnah
and the way of the companions not in
accordance to a new group or methodology
that was laid you know number of years
ago that's it I'll take two more
questions and then
maybe give him
>> I ask a question
>> yes
>> yeah I want to I want to ask advice for
like like what if you know some you know
some people who are once like they They
were once Muslim. They they grew up in a
Muslim household and they as an adult
they chose not to practice Islam. So
like now they're not they're not not
Muslim anymore, right? So like and if
you ask them why I'm not Muslim, they
give you know they give logical
reasoning and stuff and talk about how
it's how it's not compatible with the
world and stuff. So like if they were to
come to Islam again
>> or they had interest in coming to Islam
like what do you recommend we give them
or teach them help them you know come
back to Islam?
>> No I mean good question uh when you say
that you know they left Islam they left
Islam in totality right because somebody
still have weaknesses and still consider
themselves to be a Muslim. So you're
saying that they left Islam in totality.
If they come back to Islam,
you know,
except those, you know, who repent, they
rectify and they clarify, advise them to
again learn the religion because if they
if you learn the religion correctly and
you have imashi
said it, he said when it enters the
heart, it will never leave it. You know
if that iman enters the heart correctly
in the correct way with the correct
belief it will not leave it. That's why
when they came to Abuak
at the time the story of
the night journey and the ascension and
some people they left Islam because of
it and they said do you hear what your
companion is saying meaning the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam he's claiming
that he you know ascended to the heavens
and he traveled to Jerusalem in the in
the evening and they said what do you
say about that Abu Bakr he got the name
of Sadik from this incident he said if
he says it I believe him I believe him
in something more serious than that as
it relates to him receiving revelation
from Allah.
So now that firm conviction they have to
learn the religion correctly because
even logically right again and I would
advise them to sit with people who can
who have understanding of the religion
based upon the text Quran and Sunnah but
also logically are able to come with
convincing arguments. If you look in the
world today and you look at that which
plagues society, the best solutions and
the only solutions you find in Islam
wherever they are. If you look I can
like again I'll speak about
Philadelphia. If you look at
Philadelphia you see that there's a
fentanyl addiction. People are
overdosing left, right and center. They
have areas you see subhan Allah people
is like the living dead like zombies.
Islam prohibits alcohol and intoxicants
you know even alcohol
likewise any type of intoxicant also if
you look at with regards to the street
culture the knife crime Islam
alhamdulillah has many solutions the
collapse of the family structure Islam
has the solution you can't you know call
to the rect rectification of society and
you think you're going to miss the
parents one of the reasons we have so
much corruption around us is because now
people are being told you know various
things that you know there's no such
thing as gender for example and other
than that so Islam has a solution for
all of the things that are that we find
plaguing and affecting uh our societies
even as it now as it relates to
religiously based upon the text but also
as it relates to logical arguments
logical arguments is what we have to be
careful because there's a difference
between logic [cough and clears throat]
and philosophy
right
I would advise before somebody goes down
that route
Even with the logical pro proofs and
evidences like you find the scholars of
Islam first they would make sure that
they were firmly grounded in knowledge
of Quran and Sunnah that's why some
people they look they look at Islamic
and how he refuted you know the people
of logic and he also refuted the
philosophers but I remember I think it
was a
he said that was after was a mountain of
knowledge and a skull of Islam where are
you from person hasn't memorized he
thinks he's going to go out and refute
the philosophy you memorize your
so that's what I would advise you know
if for example they still have doubts
take them to people you have you have
brothers
when you see them giving dawa they use
correct logic
you know I'm not going to praise him
he's present but alhamdulillah there are
brothers that do
not using the way of the philosopher
because the philosophers they're going
to come with all types of doubts and
people would utilize that to even bring
doubts about what they are spreading
what they claim to be the Islamic
teachings
and alhamdulillah one of the things I
will say again
my from okay my time
you know giving dawa and being
involved in da in various communities
whether it's here in the UK whether it's
in other parts of the world whether it's
in the US the people that left Islam I
could probably count them on maybe two
hands you know people talk about
burnouts if I was to sit down I'd have
to think deeply about people who
actually left that I know personally
because I know like people try and throw
this out there especially you know
[clears throat] people who have from the
Sufi and other than them oh look you
know burnout rather
said and mentions it as well mentions it
in quoting from another scholar he said
it's never been known
that any person who had the correct
belief about Islam
someone who you did not find publicly
committing major and immoral filthy
acts. It's never known so and so that
the great belief there also were people
alhamdulillah they strive to be
righteous and if they committed sins
they will repent to Allah but they will
not persist on them
it's not known for anyone who was like
that that they had an evil ending it's
not known for them people who have evil
endings it's because of what they earn
with their own hands as I mentioned
again in the today when you sin black
dots are placed on the heart the more
you sin sins you know they increase the
blackness increases until eventually a
person may end up upon disbelief. May
Allah protect us all from that. That's
why you don't look down upon sins. Sins
they say the believer, he sees sins like
a mountain that's ready to collapse upon
them. May Allah forgive us all because
we will have shortcomings. Now, but the
hypocrite, he sees sins like a flight
that he just, you know, he tries to slap
the flight away because sins can amount
and they can amass and eventually it can
kill them. No. But somebody who again
has the correct belief, firm belief
about Islam, somebody who's striving to
be righteous and when they for sure they
repent repent, they said it's not known
for that type of person to have a evil.
May Allahh bless us all with them with
anything.
Vicle.